dans les hautes scèes plusieurs tours de
Nanterre construes dans les années 70
seraient menacé de destruction pour le
fils HLM du département elle coûte trop
cher à entretenir pour les élus locaux
pas question d'y toucher leurend dit
Jean-Louis Melin à mi-chemin entre
l'habitat et l'œuvre d'art des
toursnages surnommé ainsi pour leur
forme tout en rondeur et pour leur
fresque de couleur à l'intérieur une
vision du logement social qui tranchait
avec les traditionnelles bars
d'immeubles des décennies précédentes
avec mon mari on avait décidé qu'on
viendrait jamais habiter ici et puis
finalement voyez on s'y retrouve votre
premier sentiment quand vous les avez vu
j'ai trouvé que c'était l'an 2000 dans
un mauvais bouquin de science-fiction
l'an 2 c'est aujourd'hui et elles ont
pris un sacré coup de vieux ces
tournuages selon l'un des bailleurs
l'office public des HLM des hautes
scènes c'est même un gouffre financier
des fenêtres à 600 € pièces des
mosaïques à replatré en de nombreux
endroits l'Office départemental voudrait
raser les deux plus grandes tours et
reloger les locataires les intéressés
sont
partagés une
tout ai oui ça s un petit peu détérioré
mais sinon bon c'est vrai que j'avisé au
35e étage donc avec une vue sur Paris
extraordinaire c'est vrai avec une
grande luminosité d'appartements et tout
non non sincèrement je regretteraiis
effectivement le l'appartement pour la
mairie de nire pas de question de
toucher à ce patrimoine la municipalité
gère la moitié des 1700 logements et n'a
pas relevé pour sa part de frais
exorbitants bien sûr ces tours qui ont
été construites entre 77 et 80 ont
aujourd'hui besoin de travaux plus
importants mais c'est le cas je veux
dire dans tout l'ensemble du patrimoine
social et c'est même le cas dans le
patrimoine privé pas de destruction en
vue donc la municipalité prévoit au
contraire de nouveaux investissements
pour donner un nouvel élan au
quartier le bouton sur toute la France